[Aplausos]
en el instituto de antropología de la
Universidad de gotinga o el gasto y su
equipo realizan un trabajo muy minucioso
en estas cajas de cartón se encuentran
más de mil cráneos y restos humanos la
mayoría procedentes de las antiguas
colonias alemanas una colección
demasiado sensible desde el punto de
vista ético para ser filmada acá tenemos
la caja número 81
desde 2020 estos investigadores tienen
la misión de determinar su origen y
restituirlos el hallazgo del Diario de
abordo de un explorador alemán en el
archipiélago de palados en el Pacífico
aportó una pista crucial sobre uno de
ellos
desenterramos el cráneo de un hombre que
se ahogó hace más de dos años en are con
log lo hicimos en el más absoluto
secreto porque los palaulanos nunca
habían permitido que los lleváramos solo
pasamos un día en los archivos y tuvimos
mucha suerte de encontrar este documento
pero realmente nos impactó leer eso esta
colección que reúne cráneos ha quedado
en África Oriental y el Pacífico fue
constituida a principios del siglo XX
una época en la que el estudio de los
cráneos también buscaba establecer una
jerarquía entre las razas
consistía en Resaltar las diferencias
entre civilizaciones por supuesto
en interacción con la política colonial
de la época
era una forma de justificar esa política
en toda Alemania instituciones y museos
e interesan ahora por estas colecciones
que durante mucho tiempo habían caído en
el olvido
[Música]
tras haber reconocido la masacre de los
hereros y los namaco en 2004 Berlín
restituyó 20 cráneos a namibia en 2011
seguidos de otros restos unos años
después estos restos humanos fueron
sacados del sur de África tras sus
crímenes cometidos por los colonos
alemanes entre 1904 y 1908
en el centro arqueológico de Berlín
desde hace cinco años se estudian otros
miles de cráneos para determinar su
origen Exacto es un trabajo arduo según
el arqueólogo Bernard heav pero empieza
a dar sus frutos
en la colección procedente de África
Oriental tenemos 1200 cráneos y al
principio de nuestro proyecto no
sabíamos si procedían de los territorios
que hoy son Ruanda o tanzania hoy hemos
pedido determinar la procedencia de casi
todos los cráneos excepto de 7
ningún otro país ha coleccionado tantos
restos humanos como Alemania pero se
pueden encontrar colecciones similares
en muchos museos e instituciones
europeas como aquí en el Real instituto
de las ciencias naturales de Bruselas
donde estos científicos manipulan
regularmente huesos humanos en 2019
tuvieron que suspender los estudios
sobre algunas de sus piezas en
particular las osamentas de la época
colonial tiempo que este antropólogo usó
para trabajar en un informe ético en
colaboración con otros museos y cuyos
conclusiones eran publicadas en
primavera
Este es el cráneo del Rey congoleño
lucinga decapitado en 1884 fue traído
como trofeo por un general belga aún
reposa en el instituto ya no se expone
al público
pero todos los debates en torno a la
repatriación de restos humanos a su país
de origen se centran siempre en las
colecciones públicas y hay cierta
legitimidad en que se plantee la
cuestión de la responsabilidad del
estado como estado colonizador pero la
cuestión se plantea mucho menos en el
caso de las colecciones privadas que
muchas veces son tan o más grandes que
las colecciones que se pueden encontrar
en El dominio público
sin embargo la cuestión se planteó en
esta sala de subastas de la capital
belga en diciembre tres cráneos
coloniales fueron puestos en subasta
pero tras la publicación de un polémico
artículo el director retiró estas
reliquias de la venta y ofreció
restituirlas sin embargo en Bélgica la
venta de estos restos humanos es
totalmente legal
desde un punto de vista ético obviamente
son restos humanos Estamos de acuerdo es
muy penoso en cierto modo pero lo que
quería decir sobre todo es que llevo más
de 30 años en este oficio 40 incluso
cuando vendemos una momia egipcia es el
mismo problema hay un cuerpo adentro
un razonamiento que este activista no
comparte para él está osamentas no
deberían ser comercializadas
estamos viendo que los antiguos
colonialistas están muriendo por lo que
sus descendientes heredan colecciones
con las que no saben muy bien qué hacer
y las salas de subasta siguen siendo una
especie de caja negra en la que las
familias pueden blanquear un patrimonio
que normalmente sería embargado por la
justicia e iniciaría un juicio
mientras el debate sobre la restitución
de obras de arte saqueadas en antiguas
colonias está en su punto álgido las
colecciones de restos humanos en Europa
siguen siendo un gran tabú para Micaela
zelkinga especialista en el tema Esto se
debe también a que las antiguas
potencias coloniales se ven enfrentadas
a sus crímenes
hay que reconocer que la obtención de
estos restos humanos fue el resultado de
un acto de profanación el resultado de
una guerra asimétrica y finalmente todo
esto pone en primer plano la cuestión de
la reparación de la deuda moral del
reconocimiento de estas faltas
muchos museos europeos aún poseen
decenas de miles de restos humanos por
ejemplo el Museo del hombre de París
cuenta con una colección de 18.000
cráneos algunos de los cuales
procederían de colecciones coloniales el
gobierno francés ha anunciado su
intención de legislar sobre la
restitución de estos restos humanos
procedentes del extranjero en el segundo
semestre de 2023